good evening I'm Mark Austin it's seven
o'clock in London ten o'clock here in
urfa in Turkey this is a special program
on the aftermath of the devastating
earthquakes here and in Syria now no to
have killed over 7 200 people
[Music]
we're being left to Die the desperate
families digging bare-handed through the
rubble as their loved ones cry out for
help
The Race Against Time for Rescuers
accelerates we'll hear from UNICEF and
the World Health Organization later this
hour
but efforts are hampered by freezing
conditions as those who survived
struggle to keep warm
also this hour I hear the heartbreaking
story of a Turkish man from South Wales
looking for his family in the remote
village where he grew up
but amidst the stories of loss hope as a
young girl in Syria covered in dust is
lifted from the debris
[Music]
foreign
in Southeastern turkey just at one of
many cities devastated by these two
deadly earthquakes across this country
and across the border in Syria a huge
rescue operation is well underway
hundreds of people are thought to be
trapped underneath the rubble their
cries still audible some including young
children have been pulled out still
breathing but thousands more have died
and the number will rise the desperation
is now turning to anger as families
living in freezing conditions here wait
for Aid to arrive
coming up we'll bring you reports from
the front line of the rescue efforts in
some of turkey's worst hit towns and
cities at around a quarter past I'll
speak to UNICEF in the Syrian city of
Aleppo famous for the devastation it
faced in the Civil War and now facing
this new catastrophe
at 20 past we'll get an update from the
World Health Organization on the
international efforts to protect those
who have survived and at 7 40 as the
Turkish diaspora across the world rally
support I'll speak to the British
Turkish actress and love Island winner
eckenzu
but first of all tonight this report
from Alex Crawford
they're using bits of rubble
whatever they can get their hands on to
reach those buried
[Music]
anyone hear me she's shouting
they can hear sounds
so they keep calling and listening for
the loved ones who lived here
[Music]
but they've come with little more than
courage and a great deal of Hope
and their tools make barely any impact
on an eight-story building now all on
the ground floor
relatives look on sick with worry
bubbling anger growing inside
[Music]
any additional machines to supply our
machines we have no support yet from the
government
we have now Four Towers no one comes up
yeah nobody nobody are here to touch
this understand from the 40 hour I am
the one waiting here for 40 hours no one
car is came an area here now we are
dying here no it's dying okay just dying
they stand in huddles weeping and find
Comfort by talking to the trapped
children they may never see again
strong then is she saying to him be
strong we are here
the fury is real and raw the
government's not here she's shouting
enough enough
this city which hugs the Syrian border
appears to be one of the worst hit it's
home to a huge number of Syrian refugees
who fled the war to safety here and the
hatai mayor is from the main opposition
party stoking suspicions that this may
have contributed to the little Aid
evident here
we saw residents helping themselves to
food and supplies from a supermarket
which had been broken into but also saw
a television being carted away
it's because we're hungry one man told
us
desperation is haunting this city
for the love of God please help us she
begs us God I'm waiting for help she
says her husband's trapped upstairs and
they're flat and has poor sight please I
expect help from my government
so many people who feel they're not
getting the help that they need
not one person he tells us we haven't
seen a single soul here
we don't even have any water to drink or
even have any bread to eat she goes on
my daughter's in there with her two kids
another man tells us they've died in
that house
there are moments of sheer Joy a young
baby is pulled out
after so many hours she is a real living
miracle
is too young to remember what happened
but her family will remind her she's one
who beat the odds on turkey's terrible
day of earthquakes
the baby's mother has somehow kept her
alive and she too has been found they're
both badly dehydrated and the young mum
looks traumatized
this has been a terrifying experience
for them all
there are questions about how well
prepared they were here for a disaster
long predicted to happen but every time
someone is coaxed to safety and guided
down the piles of broken concrete which
were once their homes it inspires The
Rescuers to keep on going
but there are far more suffering far too
many mothers consumed by grief as the
wafer than hope they were clinging onto
finally disappears
The Rescuers don't give up though there
are frantic efforts to try to
resuscitate her boy they try and they
keep on trying
this is a young life they cannot save
this region is probably uniquely
illiquipped to cope with a natural
disaster of this scale and the heartache
and grief is going to grow over the next
few days and weeks Alex Crawford Sky
News and antakia Southern turkey
well the Syrian people are of course
those strangers to Devastation and to
suffering and after an 11-year Civil War
which has left cities in ruin and
hundreds of thousands are dead but that
trauma is now being compounded by the
impact of the earthquake and a warning
that this report from our Middle East
correspondent Alistair bunkel includes
pictures of the rescue of a young baby
found next to the body of one of the
victims
this is why there is still some hope
a little girl called North is gently
pulled out from the remains of her home
in Northwest Syria The Rescuers
encourage her to talk to her father who
is standing nearby waiting to hug his
daughter
of course these moments of Hope are
vastly outnumbered by the discovery of
dead bodies they are finding more and
more every hour
the Syrian white helmets are working
around the clock and with little
International Help
they must feel that the world has
forgotten about them but Aid agencies
haven't reached the area yet simply
because they just haven't been able to
negotiate a way across the one border
crossing that is currently open
[Music]
this is Aleppo before the war it used to
be Syria's commercial hub then it became
the center of intense fighting now it
looks like this the city is under Syrian
regime control and present Assad's
government has asked for international
Aid
a Russian cargo plane landed in Syria
today but after years of defying the
West Assad might now be forced to accept
their help
we need heavy equipment ambulances and
firefighting Vehicles we don't have fire
fighting vehicles to put out fires we
don't have heavy equipment to conduct
rescue operations there are a lot of
issues surfacing now due to the
sanctions sanctions against the Syrian
people
in another Syrian Town another moment of
relief at first this young child appears
to be lifeless and then
[Music]
they carefully scrape away the rubble
and pull him free coughing from the dust
in his throat
the body of a woman lies next to the
baby
the difference between life and death
was only a matter of inches Alistair
bunkel Sky News
and we can now go to the Syrian city of
Aleppo and speak to Angela Kearney the
UNICEF representative in that city thank
you very much indeed for being with us
and just first of all what are you able
to tell us about the situation on the
ground there
yeah well it was actually random um
buildings that came down in Aleppo and
of course we all know you're reporting
it that it was at 4 15 in the morning in
the winter time so a really tough time I
think everybody in the leopard came down
from their massive apartment rocks into
the streets and so many people haven't
got back into their homes because
they're not safe or they feel very
unsafe with the aftershocks and so
yesterday we saw real bewilderment on
children's faces standing out in the wet
and the cold looking for shelter with
their parents and you know there's been
so much War here and now this on top of
it it's really really tough for families
yeah and I just wonder if you could
expand on that how badly are children
being impacted clearly more suffering
and presumably more orphans
yeah certainly we haven't got a large
number of unaccompanied children because
uh wider family members have taken them
but we're already if that was to come up
but rather
um what's happened is that many of the
families have had to take shelter in
churches or mosques or in schools
schools some of them have been damaged
but many those schools are not made for
adults and children to sleep in so yes
as your images are showing you know it's
concrete floors two nights sleeping on
concrete floors but without blankets of
course the age is really stepping up
today we had water tankers out
delivering water so the sanitation Works
in these schools and these shelters we
are looking at special nutrition needs
we're not here alone UNICEF is part of
the United Nations that actually works
with Partners on the ground but the
needs are just so many and uh of course
there was a lot of uh there's still a
lot of broken bones and Emergency
Operations that are happening in the
hospitals and you know you think about
that those doctors those nurses those
lab technicians they're mums and Dad's
selves and thus having to leave their
families and go and look after the
others these people are really really
doing it tough
yeah I was going to ask you what is the
situation given the years of conflict
there and now this what is the situation
with Hospitals and Clinics and medical
facilities for children
yeah I mean that leading to triage and
side I also heard one of my staff was
telling me today that people are going
to the hospital because it feels safe
for them when they're so anxious and you
know have the real psychological
problems related to this after all so
many years of war and there's actually a
lot of poverty in Syria as well and so
these children have had multiple layers
of poverty and this is just one thing
more on top of course we were able
actually yesterday to buy some supplies
for the hospitals in the local market
and have them delivered to the operating
theaters direct you know with money you
can do a lot but the needs are just so
so many
and what are you able to do
about the trauma that all this causes
the trauma of conflict the trauma now of
the earthquake have you got people in
there who can help these children deal
with what they're experiencing
yes we do have a limited number of
social workers and people who are
chained in this psychosocial work but
it's actually teaches its parents it's
Sports Masters and mistresses that will
really make a difference in these
children's lives so once we settle down
a little bit and hopefully the schools
can be can become schools again you know
we'll have to support some teacher
training so that the teachers know how
to give special care to children who
have been frightened the aftershocks are
frightening uh and you know when when
are they going to stop so yes there are
some trade social workers we're going to
need many many more and a lot of this
happens where youth can help young
children
um you know parents can help other
parents and it's a lot of work that we
need to do on building those Community
structures
and do you think there will be more
Syrian families trying to flee across
the border into turkey as so many have
done in the past
the aid here because the people we need
to give them what they deserve what's
their right which is blankets and food
and medicine and and the support and the
care so that's what we're concentrating
on
and just finally
um are you confident that you can get
enough Aid in is the UN confident in
general really not just for children
confident you can get enough Aid in
given the circumstances
yeah I think that we we need to raise
the cash we need to raise the awareness
and we thank you
and at the same time of course the
political uh discussions keep on going
through member states and that's a
different part of the U.N that does that
in the meantime UNICEF the other U.N
agencies are absolutely focused on the
humanitarian response
okay uh Angela Clooney I appreciate your
time tonight thank you very much for
coming on this special program thank you
well as we've been hearing the aid
effort to prevent further loss of life
is now in full swing our correspondence
in the Turkish city of uh gazienta this
evening and uh
um usra you were on one of the aid
flights coming into turkey today
yes yeah I was Mark we were on the third
flight into gazienta from Qatar Qatar is
Turkey's one of turkey's closest allies
they had sent military personnel to help
with search and rescue but also
emergency aid supplies they pledged to
send a hundred tons of humanitarian Aid
and they're not alone the UAE has
pledged to build a field hospital and
just as we've been here in the airport
today we've seen teams come in we saw an
Israeli relief team earlier but now a
British team of 77 search and rescue
Specialists with four sniffer dogs has
arrived they've told us they've worked
they're working closely with the Turkish
authorities who've sent them coordinates
and they'll be traveling to those
coordinates as soon as possible and
working hand in hand with other
International rescue teams to try and
take advantage of this 48-hour window
which is the most critical window in
immediate response and try and save as
many lives as possible president erdogan
was very quick to ask for international
support he made a very strong appeal for
help from his Partners all over the
world we've seen pledges come in from
India from South Korea which called
turkey a brother Nation Mexico and L.A
County team is flying in which has a lot
of disaster relief expertise so what we
have been seeing a lot of solidarity on
that front and the hope is that that
solidarity can make a dent in what is a
shockingly
high and continuing to escalate Dettol
and the user just before you go give us
a sense of the scene there in that City
I mean just as we've been here in the
airport in the VIP room of the of the
airport terminal we've seen families
with babies there is a real sense of
shock it feels kind of like there was no
expectation that this would hit so hard
and gazian tap is is the city closest to
the epicenter of the 7.8 earthquake one
of the two we saw on Monday it seen mass
destruction buildings collapsing so
there is a sense that there's not even a
real understanding yet of how much
damage there really is and how many
people have actually died
thank you very much indeed
Sky News a special program from Turkey
this evening coming up we'll be speaking
to the World Health Organization about
their efforts to try and help what could
well be a humanitarian disaster here in
turkey and in Syria
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to Southern turkey let's
get more now on the efforts of the
International Community to prevent what
could become a humanitarian disaster
here and what is unfolded in the past 24
hours from becoming a real Public Health
crisis joining me now from Copenhagen is
Dr Hans Kluger he is the world health
organizations Regional director for
Europe thank you very much indeed for
being with us and a shattering
earthquake in mid-winter in heavily
populated areas is the stuff of
nightmares isn't it
absolutely who has declared this a grade
3 emergency meeting that we're working
across
with a lot of resources W2 headquarter
the two regions the Eastern
Mediterranean and European region and
our country offices combining the
efforts the key issue now is search and
rescue because there's a critical window
of 48 hours if people are entrapped
to find survivors number two safe
shelter because still only today there
are more than 230
aftershocks
and then third of course throma injury
so all hands on deck
and when it comes to helping helping
people treating people getting people
into Hospitals and Clinics so many have
been damaged here that is a real problem
isn't it
absolutely and I would like to commend
the Turkish authorities for reaching out
internationally immediately of course
turkey has a lot of experience
themselves but this is a huge size of
Emergency Medical Teams or flying in who
also dispatched
two planes with medical supplies
the immediate support is about trauma
injuries but also Burns and
electroshocks in places where the energy
infrastructure has been hit but already
we should prepare for the second wave
meaning mental health issues and also if
the water and sanitation is hit then to
be ready for outbreaks of infection
diseases
and what is the World Health
Organization able to do what sort of
position is the World Health
Organization in to be able to to help
with this
well we did have before this terrible
earthquake quite some staff in gaussian
dip for example through which
already supplies were
predisposed for Northwest Syria it's
very important that the International
Community agrees on a humanitarian
Corridor and opens the Hawa across
border point and we're working of course
hand in hand with the authorities in
Turkey also the East Mediterranean with
the counterparts on number one providing
trauma and medical supplies number two
doing an assessment of the public health
risks that for sure will come very soon
and thirdly an assessment of the current
facilities because for example our own
office in gazuntec has cracks so our own
staff had to sleep last night in their
cars in a harsh winter because we are
not sure still about the safety of the
buildings
well exactly we've spoken to many people
here who say they're simply refusing to
go back inside they don't want to spend
another night inside at the moment and
with these extraordinarily low freezing
temperatures that is another major issue
for you know people like yourselves to
deal with
absolutely safe shelter is a critical
issue and actually what you see is what
we always see in such a intrinsic
circumstances
that it exposes
the vulnerable people they're about
23 million people now in Turkey
potentially in need of humanitarian
assistance of which 5 million be
classified as vulnerable meaning
children elderly people about 15 million
in Syria were neat but this can increase
so while we hope for the best we have to
prepare for the worst because we know
that in this kind of circumstance the
Testo and the number of people with
heavy injuries can still exponentially
increase
the Border as you suggested
um you've got me back sorry I lost my
microphone for a moment getting help
across the border Dr Kluger into Syria
as you suggested is a major problem
right so
that's why it's
always
fortunately through our office
16 hospitals in Northwest Syria got
orange supplies predisposed but this is
a very very critical moment or a whole
of Syria approach
thank you very much indeed this is Sky
News a special program from Southern
turkey this evening uh coming up we'll
be speaking to someone who's helping
Syrian refugees here in Turkey
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this evening one of the many places
across the region dealing with the
aftermath of uh yesterday's appalling
earthquake well over 40 hours after the
first earthquake hit let's bring you up
to date with all the key
developments this evening and more than
7 200 people are now known to have died
but that number is very likely to rise
still further the Turkish government
says more than 20 000 people have been
injured again the real figure likely to
go much higher
three British Nationals are confirmed to
be missing in the aftermath of the
earthquake and a plane carrying 77
search and rescue Specialists from the
UK has now arrived in gaziente about two
hours from where we are here
well we saw earlier this hour the search
for survivors in the city of antakia
well 80 miles north in the city of
osmania it is a very similar story of
rarely realized hope our International
correspondent John Sparks is there
in a small corner of the city of osmania
the sound of heavy machinery fills the
air
their metal Scoops moving Rubble as the
members of a rescue team searched the
concrete slabs looking for signs of life
then a call goes out
[Music]
All Quiet on the site and the frenzied
sound of digging swiftly ends
foreign
can you hear me tap on the side of the
wall
[Music]
but these desperate questions go
unanswered
there are hundreds of people here but it
is
silent
but they haven't heard anything
there's nothing
five apartment blocks occupied the area
the residents asleep when the earthquake
struck and it seems unlikely that anyone
survived
everything then
Hope was fading and the Outlook bleak
we listen to the anguish tone of those
looking on
[Laughter]
yesterday the governor came here said
this woman but he does nothing there are
young children in these buildings but
they do nothing
a couple of hundred meters away near the
City Central Square we found a similar
scene
another human tragedy
there was a man staring at a pile of
rubble he said he was waiting for his
brother the only thing he could do do
you think it's possible that your
brother is is still alive
up to 15 people are missing no one's
really sure
but this man knows his father is here he
just found his trousers what have you
found
mother father
it's your father's childhood
is it possible that your father could
survive this
foreign
[Music]
the local highways are clogged
the supplies and the Specialists stuck
in traffic and many Regional roads are
now impossible
but they are desperately needed in this
city of debris
John Sparks Sky News in osmania
well one of the Striking features of
This Disaster is the breadth of the area
affected and also the depth of the
resources human and technological that
are being deployed to help a team of 76
British search and rescue Specialists
have arrived this evening in Turkey
along with their equipment and their
search goals our data and forensics
correspondent Tom Cheshire looks now at
the rescue effort they face
this is a gigantic search and rescue
effort more than 16 000 rescue Personnel
in Turkey alone because it's a gigantic
search area I want to show you some of
the extent of that we'll start in Turkey
in Mirage and show you what's been
happening there this is near the
epicenter of it and we've seen some of
the scenes of destructions but we'll
also see how the search and rescue is
operating because on a lot of it on the
face of it it seems like it can be on a
quite ad hoc basis because it's so hard
to get to people we have seen Emergency
Services here but they are sort of
picking through it
um that is similar to other places and
again just to talk about the Aleppo in
Syria is a long long way away from the
epicenter but it was still really badly
damaged in this and we can see again
some of the search and rescue tactics
happening we're going to talk about this
in here we'll just take you through it
again look at this Devastation so we
have this it does again look sort of
impromptu bear in mind that uh Digger
we'll just go a bit forward so we can
show you the whole scene and really
understand what's going on so you even
though this looks like there may not be
quite the full monty in terms of it what
we do have is we have a digger here
another Digger there and what they're
doing is they're not getting in on the
middle instead you have the people here
so that means they can pick through by
hand look for people they may be locals
who know the area the diggers not
getting involved because they don't want
to do damage thyro but just in case
there are people inside now there are
other parts which have better equipment
and that enables a bit more of a
response this is also in Syria and
opposition held area where the white
helmets operate and you can see uh just
here actually or just put that out for
you just in case you can't make it out
that is a big concrete cutter and that
really changes what search and rescue
teams can do we'll just roll it through
this and you'll see what happens uh in
this video we'll take you through and
you can see
it being used here we go there so that
means they can just do a lot more than
those people we saw in the first video
in terms of other capabilities that is a
big bit of Kit is handheld I want to
show you what we've got here another
really challenging recipe you've got a
generator coming up here but we're less
interested in the generator than what
they're going to attach to it and we'll
just bring that forward a slightly for
you
um this is a bit of a bit of hydraulic
kit just coming in here if you just
watch that come down and those are
basically huge uh it's a combination
tool which comprise and also bite into
things so as we go into this really
challenging I mean look how tight that
is look how tough those conditions are
but even in this very very small space
you can get that sort of equipment in it
so we just look at the end of this video
we'll see this worker
I'll just see if we can magnify that so
you can see that he's using that Tool uh
to really get in in ways that he
wouldn't be able to do now there is even
more advanced Tech on its way because 70
countries have offered assistance and
we've seen some of what they'll be
bringing this is from the Philippines
this is a vibroscope so it's got um
headphones here you've got this long
pole and that long pole has a camera on
the top it's extendable so you can feed
that through the rubble look for people
when you find them communicate them tell
them that help is on its way the Italian
firefighters originally their four chord
they posted this video you can see
that's another of those Concrete Cutters
that we saw uh from earlier
um another big hydraulic chomping tool
there we've got this fan which is useful
so that will blow uh if you're stuck in
a confined space CO2 perhaps building up
this will help ventilator space or maybe
there's just other things to buy a bit
more time so there's a lot of Kit going
in uh we can see all of this is being
prepared that's actually the same sort
of shares we saw earlier in that video
from the white helmet but despite all
this kid which is going to be helpful
there's another bit that's going to be
just as helpful which is a lot less
high-tech but just really vital spoiled
the surprise there but
here you can see dogs sniffer dogs are
going to be a vital part of this effort
in terms of finding humans there's a lot
of tech we have other things which can
track mobile phones for instance but
sniffer dogs really really important for
this effort and lots of those teams will
be arriving they'll be getting to those
zones as quickly as they put they can
because it is a vital period search and
rescue experts say that between one and
three days after disaster that is the
golden period for saving people now
Wednesday is day three so time is of the
essence
Tom Cheshire there well we can go now to
the city of gaziem tech which in normal
times is about two hours up the road
from here we can speak to uh Julia
banachi who is program officer at the
kids rainbow a children's no not at all
thank you for being with us I'll just
explain that it's a children's charity
working in that City uh with um well
particularly Syrian refugees just uh
tell me first of all Julia what is the
work you do with these Syrian refugees
so usually what we're doing we're
offering known for my education
we are offering known for my education
uh um lessons and we have a center of
providing all Society control support
and Families
the situation that we're facing right
now like we I'm sorry I'm I'm getting
destroyed from the computer yeah
sorry I'm sorry
are you able to carry on
I'm getting this to everybody
okay well look maybe
um maybe Julia will try and come back to
you that may be the best thing
yeah World Cup
yeah yeah we we will come back to you
Julia don't don't worry uh for now
um let me just uh uh tell you what's
going on here and it is uh it's a scene
of um well they're searching uh as they
have been
um in the last 40 hours they continue uh
to search and there are every now and
then these moments of of Silence uh
there was one um not long ago and uh
they then just listen and hope that uh
that they can hear someone uh who are
somehow down there in a void in a space
and who is still alive and they tell me
that this search will go on uh
throughout the night they are not going
to give up well around five and a half
million people of uh Turkish Heritage
live in uh Western European countries a
large proportion of those are in the UK
and some of the more famous members of
that diaspora are rallying support
for those affected here we can now speak
to eken sue children
a British Turkish actress a model and
television
personality thank you very much for
being with us and I just well Wonder
first of all what do you make of this
awful disaster
it's honestly so heartbreaking because
it's it's my inheritage I'm Turkish and
I've got so many family and friends out
there and you know we always live on
edge in Turkey I lived in Turkey for two
years you just never know we any
movement we're always scared of the next
earthquake there was predictions made
you know many years ago that there'll be
a big earthquake in Istanbul I always
lived in fear when I lived in Istanbul
but the fact that this has hit many
cities and it's literally affected a big
capacity of turkey and Syria is is is so
sad so devastating and I just you know
we're all a nation we need to help each
other we need as much people to donate
and um and help everyone there's a lot
of bodies buried underneath those
buildings
and he recorded this appeal for the Red
Cross tell us about that
so I recorded that truly to speak up I
wanted to use my platform as I knew that
you know I had quite a big following and
I just wanted to reach out and support
obviously the British red red team and I
just wanted to make sure that you know
there is support out there we're trying
our best
to help you know we've got the first
injured AIDS set out there and um I just
want to help as much as I can I've you
know funded myself
um as many times as I could using the
website and I just wish a little bit of
anyone's help would would be great
because we need people to to save those
people that are buried under the ground
and why is it so important to you to do
that and do you think that you can reach
you know a much broader audience as it
were
that's right and I believe using
obviously my platform I wanted to reach
as many platforms as I could you know
anyone in the UK or whoever whoever was
following me from obviously what I was
on before and I just want to to shout
here again please help you know we've
got children families friends desperate
in need of your help
um I I cannot emphasize this more it's
really sad it's really heartbreaking
we're a nation we're in this together
you know and um
yeah it's I'm lost for words it's it's
my it's my hometown it's my it's my
country you know
I wish I could be there right now
Yeah well yeah I was going to ask you
whether you might uh come across with
the Red Cross but I just wondered what
do you have friends and family who have
been directly caught up in this
so I have members of my family and who
have obviously experienced the shake
that they've been outside they've been
sleeping outside it's it's scary because
it's people who are very close to me you
know I've had numerous people um on
Instagram reach out to me they've sent
me locations of an address pictures live
and it's like they are screaming for
help and I want to use my platform as
much as I can to help you know anyone
out there from Syria and turkey
and of course that's the big fear here
in Turkey major earthquakes they live
with that fear
um you know all the time do you think
there's an issue about the preparedness
of the country four major earthquakes in
terms of building regulations and so
forth do you think there is an issue
about you know the way turkey is
prepared or not prepared for these
um events I I would like to to believe
that certain
um buildings which were built
um well are earthquake proof as I should
say but then some aren't and
unfortunately most parts of the
buildings are old in turkey and they're
very easily they can be damaged they can
crack and again if there is an
earthquake to to occur unfortunately
that's going to be destroyed but you
know Turkey is working the government is
working on making better uh buildings
more strong stable earthquake proof and
um I think that's the only way we can
move forward because
unfortunately you know earthquakes do
happen
um in turkey and Syria and most most
countries almost every month but it's
the it's the big ones that scare us it's
the ones that you know we lose friends
family people that's the one that's
that's really scary
yeah and and certainly uh this was an
extremely powerful one just finally 30
seconds left
um you mentioned you'd like to be out
you know would you come out with the Red
Cross do you see there's a you know
there could be a purpose in that yes
as soon as the opportunity it was given
to me I am there
um obviously it's my home it's my second
language and anything I can do I'm there
to support anyone so first opportunity
I'll be there
okay I can see thank you very much for
coming on appreciate your time
this is Sky News a special program this
evening from Southern turkey coming up
the heartbreaking story of a Turkish man
from South Wales looking for his family
in the remote village where he grew up
[Music]
stories don't always come from big
cities
I'm Lisa Dowd and I'm Sky's Midlands
correspondent and this is where I grew
up we can reveal that the driver who hit
Harry Dunn is 42 year old and sakulas
just met the president and he never
thought we'd get this far this what
they're up against the wind is the real
problems
[Music]
been working well water levels are
dropping but no one knows what impact
further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world it's really scary
we're terrified in this community until
that everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
I never knew they would make it it's
amazing
it seems tantalizingly close in this
corner of the UK Wales was the first to
introduce the plastic bag charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
the band has rallied moderation interest
rates peaking and up at six percent the
highest for 14 years will that be the
peak will it be a little bit lower
prices it's closer to a potential crash
so many words so many meanings but what
do they mean for you and your finances
stay up to date on Sky News
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
now Turkish families in the UK awoke on
Monday to the horrifying news from here
many have rushed over to try to reach
loved ones in the earthquake zone we
came across armatic illness from South
Wales struggling to get to the remote
Village of Tut in the Taurus Mountains
where he was born and where he grew up
we decided to try to help him get there
and what we found was heartbreaking
is a Broken Man
we came across him amid the chaos of one
of the few functioning airports here
they made the journey from South Wales
he is desperately trying to find a way
to reach the Mountain Village he grew up
in I mean it's completely collapsed this
is what is left of his brother Ali's
house Ali is dead his wife seriously
injured and two of his children are
missing in the rubble
we decide to take him or at least to get
as close as we can
halfway there he gets a call from his
surviving niece to say no one is coming
to help them Ahmed cannot bear it
once we're up in the mountains it is not
an easy Journey
we finally reached the village the
damage the reality of it all
[Music]
and for Ahmet reunited with his sister
fatter the uncontrollable grief
oh yeah
also waiting for him his surviving niece
sidca
her sisters ashigul and Zara that they
are looking for now
it is heartbreaking
[Music]
tells me it was a house full of joy and
love and now his family is destroyed so
Ahmed just tell me when you see this
what goes through your mind
unbelievable
foreign
he says the locals want to know where
the government help is the truth is the
government is overwhelmed
what would your message be I said where
are you we need the people accommodation
with everybody's trees here they've been
only locals people they can't neighbors
or friends they would try Apple where is
government
in these remote snowy Villages they will
have a long wait
I'm very sorry for your loss yeah very
sorry
I can't believe
one man facing the enormity of it all in
this country of countless tragedies
and so the search and rescue operations
go on across this city across many
cities in turkey and of course across
the border in Syria here behind me they
seem to be closing in on one particular
area and uh quite clearly from what
they're doing and from what they're
saying they have not given up hope of
finding someone alive they still think
although it is now 42 hours or so after
this earthquake they still think that it
is possible that they could find someone
alive and so the search goes on well
that is just about it from this special
program we will leave you uh now with
some of the pictures of Devastation and
human resilience that we've seen over
the past 48 hours
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this baby